quand la bombe pour pieds et que leur
seul mois pour pour les micro trottoirs
de gérard à biot une réflexion revient
très souvent au fil de vos pages c'est
normal que les gens ne sachent plus rien
les études ne sont plus ce qu'ils
étaient de mon temps on apprenait les
départements les préfectures et les
sous-préfectures pas de calais chez plus
arras et ben oui ça a bien changé pour
se rendre compte à quel point en cette
période de grandes migrations
saisonnières
monsieur pas bio a voulu connaître sur
l'eure là somme de vos connaissances en
faisant la manche micro en main dans les
rues de montpellier pas que je vous
parle de la somme en jeu c'est pas moi
je parle de lettre 10 ou 15 millions
vous placeriez vous le stum vous même
quand je vous parle de l'anjou voyez ce
que c'est qu'est ce que ça peut être
c'est à dire quand on met le physique
ont visé puis qu'on met la crosse contre
l'ajout n'avait pas l'air d'être su
comment se fait parce que je n'ai jamais
jamais jamais jamais entendu parler de
l'anjou pourquoi parce que je n'étais
pas dans les gens qui maniait des armes
de service de sentiments ni proverbe la
meuse voyez ce que c'est que la meuse
oui ça fait je me mets pas si comment
j'ai même vu un pastis pourquoi la meuse
et c'est quoi la meuse la bière je
regarde une information presque tous les
jours j'ai jamais entendu parler de lyon
dans la france est loin de saint-etienne
mais jamais non je connais très bien la
région soutiennent et de lyon vous avez
jamais entendu jamais non j'ai pas c'est
même très souvent est ce que vous en
pensez
tous les jours je pense qu il y a des
lions je serai peut-être que des bêtes
lâchées par le ménach oeil ou placeriez
vous l'aube l'aube mais disons que moi
je la passerai plus tôt à l'est c'est à
dire les et la france l'a dit ou fait
dire ça c'est le soleil se lève à l'est
et donc il me semble que logiquement le
soleil loupes devrait apparaître le plus
tôt à l'est de la france si je prends la
france comme dans une grande ville de
l'aube une grande ville de lomme je
dirais strasbourg la touraine ça vous
dit quelque chose à touraine
c'est dans le jus de la belote en impôts
on dit en tout cas où tous très fort en
toupie cas on ne vit pas à trouver la
touraine ça n'existe pas que pensez-vous
du pas de calais je suis pas me parler
du pas de calais je sais pas qu'est-ce
que qu'est ce que ça veut dire
à votre avis non mais qu'est ce que ça
veut dire pas de calais à votre avis
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pas de calais
qu'est ce que vous entendez par pas de
calais qu'est ce que vous entendez vous
même dans pas de calais mais moi j'en
paye moi je sais pour moi qui pose la
question c'est vous bah oui je vous dis
pas de calais à votre avis et le
sancerrois alors ce serait quoi c'est à
dire comme ça tu vois c'est à dire alors
à couper la tête à qui la wii 16 et à la
doctrine un pack m
bon c'est devenu après ce day 3 jiangsu
c'est devenu la république alors le
sancerrois jusqu'à la république ouais
si je vous dis dijon dijon de gens n'en
dijon dijon 10 jan je vous dis dijon ça
vous manque quelque chose dijon je vous
prie de m'excuser ont rejoint ce foutu
dijon le jonc vous n'avez jamais entendu
dijon dijon ça vous dit jean jean à
moins que ce soit une ville à moins que
ce soit une évidemment sans voix à moins
que ce soit la vie la ville disons de
jeu disons la gironde ça vous dit
quelque chose à g rendre à guérande
c'est une femme très bien fait avec des
formes avantageuses
c'est vous voyez je vois pas du tout ça
de moi voir alors la gironde une forme
de joie
je dois préciser quand même que dans ses
interlocuteurs il y avait un recteur
d'académie c'est pour vous dire que ta
bio il piège tellement ses
interlocuteurs il pose les questions un
peu biaisé comme ça que certains se
laissent avoir souvent très
sympathiquement voilà c'est dit